did you know fairies long ago were
notorious for their insatiable bloodlust
and violence picture tiny misbehaving
winged beings sipping from human veins
they're like bats made of nightmares in
some pre-celtic folklore fairy strength
the blood of sleeping humans or they
would mix the blood into dough some
Scotch fairies needed human blood to
survive hello darkness way back fairies
were generally seen as something to fear
in 1682 the secret Commonwealth of elves
fawns and fairies folklorus Robert Kirk
describes fairies as Celestial Misfits
the adorable teeny gentle fairies in
popular culture today owe their
sweetened reputation to 19th century
fairy tales like Peter Pan's Tinkerbell
and other folklore collections with
colorful illustrations and appealing
stories of ethereal winged faithful and
also the whole codingly fairy photo
phenomenon